استمرار اعلان حاله الطوارئ الصحيه القصوى
العامه ذات الاهتمام الدولي قرار مفاجئ
جاء بعد الاستماع الرابع عشر للجهه
الطوارئ العالميه منذ بدايه الازمه
ومروري ثلاث سنوات من اعلان المرض حاله
صحيه طارئه ذات ابعاد عالميه
فقبيل الاجتماع الاخير اشار الرئيس منظمه
الصحه العالميه الى ان المرحله الطارئه
للوباء لم تنتهي بعد لاسباب عده
وارتفاع اعداد الوفيات كان من ابرز اسباب
استمرار حاله الطوارئ القصوى
لا يزال حاله طوارئ صحيه عالميه وانا
اوافق على ذلك مع دخولنا العام الرابع
للوباء ليس هناك شك في اننا في وضع افضل
بكثير الان مما كنا عليه قبل عام عندما
كانت موتته في ذروتها
منظمه الصحه العالميه كانت ابلغت الاسبوع
الماضي عما يقرب من 40 حاله وفاه معظمها
في الصين
استمرار الاصابات والوفيات بسبب كرونا
والمتحورات المرتبطه به جعلت الصحه
العالميه تتراجع عن رفع تصنيف الجائحه عن
الوباء
وابقت على حاله القلق العالمي سلطان
العربيه